all right hey palsies my name is cody
and i'm a helpster that means a monster
who helps and because i love love love
to help so much i'm making these videos
called helpsters
help you
if you know me you know i love high
fives and handshakes i even have a song
about them
high fives and handshakes
what a difference a plan makes but what
if you're not close enough to give
somebody a high five or a handshake or
or or what if somebody doesn't like them
as much as you do and they say no thank
you please what do you do then well good
news i thought of two new things you can
do instead of high fives and handshakes
yeah these things are so great because
you can do them if someone is far away
or if you're talking to someone on video
or you can even do them to yourself in
the mirror but i'm not gonna tell you
what these two things are
i'm gonna sing about them instead
music please
bright smiles and hand waves
shining out like the sun's rays cause
the sun may be distant but it's still
warm and bright with a smile you can
share with everybody in sight all right
no matter how far the brighter you glow
the better for reaching everybody you
know shining out like the sun's rays
bright smiles and hand waves
bright smiles and hand waves
bright smiles and hand waves
thanks for watching and i'll be back
soon until then make sure to help the
people and monsters around you because
everyone loves a helping hand bright
smiles and hand waves everybody
helpsters
help you
you